Salut les Mentalos
Ici le commissaire Fabien
aujourd'hui je vous fais passer un test
pour intégrer le CBI, FBI Youtube ou je sais pas quoi.
Hier j'ai reçu par mail une énigme de Mike, Mike qui habite à Dublin.
Mike tu peux commenter pour dire: "Oui c'est bien moi qui t'ai envoyé un mail."
J'ai trouvé son énigme tellement intéressante que je vous en fait part aujourd'hui.
Comme si c'était un test pour rentrer en tant que mentaliste dans la police.
Et ça rime...!
Ce qui est amusant c'est que j'ai trouvé une réponse à cette énigme
et quand Mike m'a envoyé sa réponse ce n'était pas la même.
Donc c'est cool!
En fin de vidéo je vous donnerai les deux réponses
Mais essayez de la trouver par vous même avant.
C'est quand même beaucoup mieux.
Imaginez:
Vous êtes renfermé dans une salle
devant vous il y a une bombe qui est prête à exploser.
Le compteur tourne.
Pour la désactiver il faut que VOUS entriez un code.
Vous n'avez qu'une seule chance, en cas d'erreur la bombe explose
Devant la bombe il y a trois personnes
et c'est trois personnes ont un t-shirt sur lequel est marqué un code
L'un des codes est le bon
Mais on vous a prévenu, c'est trois personnes sont légèrement dérangées
Un dit tout le temps la vérité. Il dit la vérité quoi qu'il arrive, on l'appelle dans le métier
"L'honnête"
Il y en un autre dans le tas, on ne sait pas lequel, rien ne les différencie.
Il ment tout le temps, quoi qu'il arrive.
On l'appelle "Le Filou"
Je l'aurai pas forcément appeler le Filou, mais Mike l'a appelé le Filou alors je l'appelle le Filou
Troisième...
Des fois il ment, des fois il dit la vérité.
Des fois il dit deux fois la vérité d'affilée
On ne sais jamais ce qu'il va dire. Pourquoi?
Parce qu'il s'en fout.
On l'appelle "l'Indécis"
Les trois entre eux savent qui est qui
il y a juste vous qui ne savez pas qui est qui, vous ne pouvez pas les différencier.
Vous jetez un coup d'œil sur le compte à rebours
et vous comprenez que vous avez juste le temps de poser trois questions
avant que la bombe explose.
Alors il va falloir être bon et efficace sur ces trois questions.
Un flash apparaît,
votre dernier souvenir c'est d'avoir appuyé sur le bouton de désamorçage de la bombe
Car VOUS avez réussi à désamorcer la bombe
La police arrive sur les lieux et vous dit:
"Mais comment avez-vous réussi à déterminer qui était qui avec seulement trois questions"
Et c'est vrai...
Comment vous avez réussi?
Sachant que vous avez comme information que c'est celui qui dit toujours la vérité qui possède le bon code sur son tee-shirt
Je vous laisse réfléchir à ça, je donne ma réponse et celle de Mike à la fin après la outro
J'espère que vous allez faire partie du CBI, FBI ou ce que tu veux qui finit en "I"
Et surtout que cette nouvelle vidéo vous a plu!
Si c'est le cas vous me le faites savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air c'est très important
Et n'oubliez également de vous abonnez avant de partir
Puisque le mentalvlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h. Ciao!
Alors je commence par vous donner ma réponse
on va imaginer que les trois personnes sont dans un ordre précis
donc on va appeler "1", "2" et "3".
Je vais m'adresser au numéro deux et je vais lui dire:
"Si je te demande est-ce que "1" est celui qu'on appelle l'Indécis, est-ce que tu vas me répondre "oui"?"
Soit il me répond "oui" à cette question et cela veut dire que c'est lui-même l'Indécis ou alors que c'est "1" l'Indécis".
Parce que tout l'intérêt de faire une question comme ça
c'est que même si c'est "1" l'Indécis et que là je m'adresse au Filou, il est obligé de me répondre "oui".
C'est une question dans la question
donc si c'est le Filou qui me répond et que "1" est l'Indécis pour que vous compreniez bien
il serait obligé de me répondre "oui" puisqu'il devrait répondre "non" à cette question dans la question
mais comme il ment toujours alors il est obligé de transformer en "oui"
En clair on hack le système et on hack la question
Et si il me répond "non" ça veut dire que soit "2" est l'Indécis: je sais toujours pas.
Par contre ça veut dire que quoi qu'il arrive "1" n'est pas l'Indécis.
Donc s'il me répond "non" quoi qu'il arrive je sais que "1" n'est pas l'Indécis
Donc à la fin de cette question soit je saurai que "1" n'est pas l'Indécis soit je saurai que "3" n'est pas l'Indécis.
J'aurai cette info là.
Deuxième question, je vais m'adresser à la personne dont je suis certain que ce n'est pas l'Indécis.
Donc "1" ou "3" suivant la réponse précédente.
Si je te demande si c'est toi l'Honnête, est-ce que tu vas me dira "oui"?
Si il est l'Honnête, il dira "oui" quoi qu'il arrive
et donc je sais que c'est l'Honnête et c'est terminé en deux questions seulement j'ai pu désamorcer la bombe.
J'ai même gagner une question, j'ai le temps de prendre un petit café!
Si c'est le "filou", il doit me dire "non".
Alors qu'on comprenne bien le principe de la question dans la question.
En temps normal si la question était franche, il sait qu'il me dirait "non". Il répondrait pas "oui", il répondrait "non".
Donc comme c'est un menteur, il doit inverser et me dire "oui", et donc au moment où il doit dire "oui"
Comme c'est une deuxième question dans la question, il est obligé de ré-inverser, il va me dire "non".
Et je sais que c'est le menteur!
Et si c'est le menteur dans ces cas-là j'utilise la troisième question pour lui dire
est-ce que "2" est l'Indécis et j'inverse sa réponse tout simplement.
Comme ça je peux déduire qui est la personne honnête et désactiver la bombe.
Alors la réponse de Mike elle est différente
parce qu'elle joue sur une proportion de valeur qui est très intéressante au départ.
Mike je pense que tu regarderas cette vidéo, j'aimerai bien que tu mettes ta réponse dans les commentaires
et nous on likera le commentaire pour que ça devienne le top commentaire et qu'on puisse l'avoir tout de suite.
Mais je trouve ça plus intéressant que ça soit toi qui l'explique parce que le processus pour trouver ça
très honnêtement j'y aurai pas penser
et c'est plutôt pas mal, surtout la première phase.
Je sais pas si vous aviez trouvé vous même une autre réponse à ça
moi j'ai bien galéré quand même avant de lui répondre
j'ai dû passer deux trois heures dessus hier.
Donc si vous avez une réponse vous la mettez dans les commentaires.
Et puis voilà à demain! Ciao!